l accès aux vaccins en préoccupent tout
particulièrement décryptage avec nos
deux invités philippe emmanuel y est
ouverte aux autres jovani
bonsoir messieurs vous êtes tous les
deux médecins merci d'être avec nous ce
soir la situation aujourd'hui pose
question selon le feu s est mise 60 % de
la population au nord est vacciné contre
5% au sud trop de vaccins d'un côté pas
assez de l'autre et ce qu'elle vous
étonne cette fracture vaccinale umberto
à joe daniels et
c'est au nom des deux côtés car
premier en début de la pandémie il ya
une sorte d'aider les volontés des
globalisé on avait même vu les ducks inc
et est globalisante et donc on s'est dit
que
pour qu'elle vous l'avez loupé s'en
sortir une folie une folie certaine
solidarité
mais finalement après
bientôt lui son souvenir les échos
horizon déchets chaque pays même sous
les doses du vaccin comme chaque pays
qui tire la couverture à soi et donc
c'est pas étonnant qu'aujourd'hui on a
des pays plus riches et qui avait plus
assez accès aux semaines qui
mieux vacciner d'abord à un pays plus
pauvres qui meurent
moyenne des persuasion et même les mi
moyens économiques décès
l'approvisionner le bac c'est notre
regard philippe emmanuel et sur cette
fracture vaccinale cette situation
aujourd'hui très disparates d'un côté du
monde et de l'autre
oui à cette fracture elle est connue et
elle se répète à chaque problème
sanitaire mondiale il s'est passé la
même chose pour le sida il se passe
encore la même chose pour l'hépatite b
est évidemment le kobe 19 aujourd'hui
n'est qu'une maladie supplémentaire avec
un enjeu mondial pour lequel
effectivement et bien les budgets ne
sont pas suffisants et à la hauteur pour
traiter le problème de façon globale
c'est une question de budget ou bien il
faut aussi alors comment accélérer
l'accès aux vaccins en tant que biens
publics umberto giannini
mais il ya plusieurs problèmes
faut dire aussi que le continent
africain d'un côté il est ébloui frappé
qui est
l'europe au niveau des la pandémie que
les nouveaux décès était moindre même si
on a eu des pics au niveau surtout du
pays du maghreb et tout ça et peut-être
aussi dur l'âge moyen de la population
qui est beaucoup plus basse après je
pense que la facture c'est pas que les
vaccins c'est une fracture économique
s'est fracturé d'accès aux soins c'est
toute la difficulté même d'aider des
mêmes sur les vaccins obligatoires
l'accès des vaccins obligatoires dans
les pays du sud est beaucoup plus
difficile donc la mortalité vous élever
moi j'ai su bien placé sur ça parce
qu'elle
nous quitte en ligne cambodge ce prêt
pour donner l'accès aux vaccinations
primaire pour les enfants donc si vous
voyez dans ces pays là les saucisses et
même des vaccinés pour la polio la
rougeole a encore des leaders locaux
vides il faut penser aussi l'autre
difficulté ces défis culturels cd des
enfants si il fait aussi des des
missions humanitaires qu'ils soient ne
sont pas l'accès à l'école non pas
l'accès à la culture donc même ça les
gens ne sont même pas au courant de ce
qui se passe ces derniers cités laisser
faire vacciner ou est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui du programme kovacs
philippe-emmanuel y les pays les plus
riches avaient promis on s'en souvient
en milliards de doses à ce jour elles
n'ont délivré que 15% qu'est ce qui
ferait alors au delà des symboles il
faut retracer l'histoire du programme
kovacs il faut se rappeler en fait c'est
qu'au début de l'épidémie qu'ovide où on
n'avait pas de vaccin où on ne savait
pas où on allait bien que ce sont les
pays riches le g20 qui avait appelé à la
constitution en gros d'une formation
exceptionnelle pour effectivement lutter
contre l'épidémie est donc scellé g20
qui avait ce le g20 effectivement qui
avait mandaté l'om est ce pour mettre en
place sur le programme accélérateur à ct
dont fait partie le kovacs aujourd'hui
et à l'époque évidemment tout le monde
était d'accord pour apporter des fonds
très vite le message liffré le montant
du budget et ce budget était énorme
puisque ils étaient chiffrées rien que
pour l'année 2000 21 à 31 billions de
dollars alors quand on arrive à ces
sommes-là évidemment ne sait plus de
quoi on parle alors j'ai regardé un
petit peu pour donner aux
téléspectateurs des références il faut
savoir sur le sida sur sur la politique
effectivement d'être des malades aux
malades du sida depuis 2002 c'est à dire
en vingt ans on a dépensé 50 millions de
dollars dans le monde entier donc c'est
vous dire qu'en un an 30 billions de
dollars pour le coc vide c'est énorme et
un autre chiffre également pour essayer
de comprendre l'enjeu financier le
volume mondial des ventes sur internet
aux particuliers ces 5 billion donc le
montant du budget qu'ovide en 2021
affichée par le msc
effectivement six fois le montant des
ventes internet aux particuliers donc
évidemment qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui les pays riches qui avait
lancé l'appel initialement ou la
solution et c'est eux qui étaient à
cette initiative là donc effectivement
maintenant ils sont probablement
beaucoup moins pressé effectivement de
financer ce programme est effectivement
aujourd'hui sur 31 millions et bien le
ms a récolté 16 millions et il manque à
peu près effectivement l'équivalent à
l'appel vous évoquiez ouverte aux deux
jeunes années des difficultés
culturelles il ya plusieurs autres défis
aussi on le rappelle le transport
maritime mondial et perturber certains
vaccins ex nécessite un équipement super
congélateur est ce que vous direz que le
problème aussi réside surtout dans ses
infrastructures qui manquent dans les
pays les plus pauvres
et
une partie oui et mais aussi
une part d la part des choses entre les
métropoles qui sont souvent très bien
équipée et qu'ils ont des accès
similaire à celle qui aujourd'hui avec
la mondialisation une métropole
africaine il n'est pas très différente a
encore une autre pôle européen hymne au
tripode et l'amérique le team rien à
envier à métropoles des états unis mais
les lois des différents sociaux sont si
contents alors que la suite d'un contre
la pluie une autre différence c'est de
les les coins les plus reculés la
campagne là où en europe on a déjà les
distances qui sont moindres il ya quand
même un petit suite beaucoup plus tard
c'est l'air qui seront des écoles des
hôpitaux des soins tout le reste ça dans
les pays pauvres
est passé taxé après les premiers comics
c'est qu'elle aussi nous compare
beaucoup mais l'europe c'est le seule
partie du monde où on à l'accès au ciel
tout le monde est sans frais tous les
autres pays qu'ils soient des pays
d'asie des pays d'afrique des piliers
américain les semaines sont payants bon
les états unis pour cette fois ci ils
ont fait l'exception des données eu le
bac c'est gratuit mais tous les autres
accès pour des soins de prévention de
l'été traitement dans ces pays sous
développés sont à la charge du personnel
c'est pas l'état qui les fournissent
donc ça aussi ça crée aussi des
difficultés parce que les gens ils n'ont
pas les réfugiés des relais vers l'état
des traitements gratuits de simples qui
suivront entre temps c'est un coup et le
coût d'un traitement en afrique il est
beaucoup plus élevé d'un rapport au pib
du pays restera pas en connaître en
europe certains détracteurs
certains détracteurs à philippe emmanuel
et pointe du doigt aussi ce qu'il
considère être une sorte de diplomatie
du vaccin qui écarterait des dons les
pays sans intérêt sur le plan
géopolitique quel est votre regard sur
ce point oui c'est clairement une
dimension politique il faut se rappeler
quand même que les états unis s'étaient
retirés l' oms sous la présidence trump
qu'ils y reviennent maintenant mais à
pas comptés et donc évidemment tout cela
cache les enjeux diplomatiques forts des
enjeux économiques forts et bien sûr
tous cela ne ne transparaît pas au
premier plan tout derniers mois avec
vous berthod giovannini ce sens la
vaccination dans les pays les plus
pauvres alors de la mondialisation des
échanges de flux de populations à
travers le monde on ne parviendra pas à
sortir de la crise sanitaire et du co
vide
donc ça c'est vraiment une question des
millions de dollars qui est des deux
côtés et c'est dire aussi mais ce qui
est dans ces pays finalement pas obtenir
en unités par diffusion du virus j'étais
en discussion avec des amis d'autres
soient utilisés ou les sorties aussi des
la dé la grippe espagnole et à l'époque
les attaques du bac 5 a réussi à sortir
donc il faut un petit aussi que ne sait
pas plus port davantage qui ont pas
prendre nos pays c'est qu'ils ont
globalement une population plus jeune et
les taux de mortalité les plus bas par
contre c'est fort possible qu'il en sort
d une diminuation du colis dans les pays
qui n'ont pas été vaccinés est encore là
aussi les quid des barrières et les
débats rien parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu et les virus comme l'écho ville et ça
les rives et aux échos laissent beaucoup
mieux que les médecins sont des virus
très instable et kiki mouthe tout le
temps quand même l'effet des vaccinés et
sauf à ça suffira pas il faudra faire
des rappels tous les ans avec virus qui
varie donc peut-être finalement les
paris a choisi dans des pays où la
population est fragile les vaccinations
et dans les pays où la population n'est
pas fragile faute d'aidé pas voir des
vaccins pour tout le monde espérait
qu'il l'imité grégaire arrivée permettra
d'avoir un virus est endémique wallace a
apprécié du côté
des modèles qui ont pu y cotiser mais
seulement le futur aux liens s'étaient
choix je voudrais vous faire réagir à
philippe magnoler sur cet objectif de
l'onudc qui est de vacciner 40 % la
population mondiale à d'ici fin 2021
c'est dans quelques mois 70 % d'ici
2022 le patron de l'om s il croit
visiblement il y croit encore il semble
que c'est possible d'y parvenir
il a mises en avant les outils
l'ensemble des outils qui étaient entre
les mains des dirigeants comment est ce
qu'on fait pour atteindre cet objectif
et ce qu'il vous semble possible
écouter le message du patron de l'om
mais c'est clair c'est à dire que
effectivement le oms a affiché je dirais
un plan extrêmement clair des items à
mettre en place pour atteindre ses
objectifs
mais en face de chaque item eh bien il
ya une colonne en millions et en
billions de dollars est donc cet
objectif sera tenu si d'ici deux mois et
bien effectivement l'om s obtient 16
millions de dollars supplémentaires
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cet
échange philippe-emmanuel y est ouverte
aux giovannini médecins tous les deux
merci à vous de nous avons